in indonesia's northern aceh province a
perilous and exhausting journey has
finally come to an end for these
rohingya refugees their boat which had
114 people on board had set sail from a
refugee camp in bangladesh 25 days ago
indonesian fishermen saw it land on a
beach in the early hours of sunday
morning and called the police
people here are giving them food and
shelter while the authorities complete
health checks including covid19 tests
we'll leave it to the government but
we're helping them because it's the
humane thing to do if we don't receive
them where can they go
indonesian aid workers are also helping
they say some refugees are ill after
their long journey
some of them are not feeling well one
refugee has swellings on her arms and
legs and is unable to stand or walk
while another is malnourished probably
because he's been at sea for too long
hundreds of rohingya who fled a military
offensive in myanmar have reached
indonesia in recent years but indonesia
regards itself as only a transit country
where refugees cannot permanently
resettle
so for these rohingya the danger is over
for now but the uncertainty remains as
to what their future holds victoria
gatenby al jazeera